I always kind of just like figured well
the cop interviews will just never
happen because
you know to get the approval of the
department and all that it's just that's
just not going to happen so I gave up on
it yeah it is a huge stumbling block
except for when you're retired then it's
yeah retired free game
and some of my favorite interviews on my
channel are with you know retired cops
like Mike Dowd or uh
Kevin Donaldson but uh but to have an
active cop is a whole another story yeah
I listened to the one with Kevin and uh
wow that was really good yeah it's one
of the best challenges of my channel it
seems like a really nice guy yeah
absolutely he's great it's funny um I
forgot last time we met actually
arrested one of your guys that you had
on the show I'm sure you've arrested a
lot of the guys yeah I mean yeah one of
the ones I know of of course it was just
recents it was a guy named John he was
like a male model that came from a
really oh blonde guy yes really good
looking yes he got arrested for what
it's been about maybe six months but I
think it was like um like a burglary
theft type of thing yeah these guys are
they're always stealing to make their
money for drugs yes yeah unfortunately
and the reason why I knew one of the
places we were searching for him so I
was uh I was running a fugitive
apprehension team and he was a fugitive
at the time and uh one of the he was it
was like a halfway home halfway house
type of scenario and the guy said oh
yeah he's like he's uh yeah he's he
shouldn't be hard to find he he did an
interview on this uh soft white end of
belly show and you know talking about
his life and all that and then you know
I clicked in my mind I was like oh okay
it's interesting yeah we're gonna come
across uh that all the time but yeah so
you're an active
police officer yes with LAPD on uh
unskid row right
based out of skid row but my
jurisdictions all of Southern California
where whatever crime happens in the city
of La that has a Nexus to it and it
leads to wherever that's where we're
going you've been you've been with the
department for how long I've been with
I've been I've been a cop I was
previously NYPD that's why I had um I
knew of Mike Dowd and uh going on three
decades now is that right so yeah with
NYPD and LAPD did you always want to be
a cop when you were a kid always really
yeah yeah it's uh ever since I always
try to think back you know you try to
think back how far it goes and I think I
could trace it to about maybe 11 or 12
years old what is it about being a cop
that appeals to you you know what's
changed Through The Years you know where
as as I find
as I get more in touch with myself and
my feelings and find out what really
drives me and what I'm comprised of and
DNA and forces that influence you and
change your trajectory in life uh the
thing my my soul I think purpose in life
is to be a protector and it just
happened to be law enforcement's uh
appeal to my senses at that you know
formative time of the teenage years and
I saw it as like a tribe of men
um With a Purpose with a good purpose
and then all the layers on top of that
as you go through life finding out about
I was so I grew up as a solo child so I
think I've as I've learned more about
myself I felt that a connection of
trying to connect with um you know like
a Brotherhood where I just that was
lacking in my household it was since it
was all on me I didn't have that that
kinship with other siblings so that
Police Department became like a
surrogate family so growing up in a real
uh chaotic you know irish-american
alcoholic family where there's a lot of
chaos and disruption that um
the police department was a really good
surrogate family where you had role
models and good mentors and not that I
didn't get that in my family it was just
it was that was an enhanced enhanced the
life experience and I was like wow I can
get paid to do a good thing uh have
brothers and sisters that are really
good people for a good purpose I was
like I'm all in this is great and and
then even when I do leave the police
department after you know like I said
been doing this for three decades I'm
always going to be trying to live my
life of service whether it's even now if
it's on duty or off duty like trying to
help you with your channel is uh I'm
trying to do a service to my profession
to our nation and it's great because she
could speak directly to the people this
is such a new experience where you can
take an ordinary average guy like me and
it can be seen by millions of people and
convey a message and really get across
what's going on in the streets what's
going on in the police department what's
going on in jails and to get unfiltered
truth is very rare In Our Lifetime
anyway I think and again it's just
that's my perspective so but but as you
said being of service I think is is the
key to being fulfilled in life
yes yes that's
that's what I've learned through the
years I mean and that's what's great
about the policeman you're gonna have a
direct impact of profound measures on so
on uh in the worst case scenario like
sometimes I'll arrest people in a super
down in the dumps that they got arrested
and they're thinking it's the end and I
tell no this isn't the end this is the
beginning but it's the choice is yours
it could be the beginning of a rebirth
an introduction to spirituality by
whatever means that you choose in in
jail in prison unfortunately it is not a
whole lot of resources which I think
should change if we're going to get have
be really serious about rehabilitation
in this country but there are Avenues
within this criminal justice system that
you can get help and whether it's
through religion or someone exposing you
to a trade or what have you you can make
that change and and have that spiritual
rebirth I think that's one of man's best
qualities is like that Redemption and
rebirth and that Phoenix Rising so
that's why I try to convey to the
arrestees that were just people I come
across in everyday life and as I'm
sitting here thinking that's why I like
doing these things thinking of um like
sentencing what we could do to really
enhance
rehabilitation in this country it's like
if it's possible why not if a kid gets
arrested why not sentence him to uh
being on a sports team like so many kids
especially kids in the in the ghetto in
a city that parents if they have if they
have one usually raised by grandparents
Grandma's doing all the heavy lifting
they don't have the money to put someone
into
a sports program a boxing program Jiu
Jitsu like I do and why don't we put
that structure and that discipline into
that kid's life and then if it's an
older person in their 20s or whatever
you can never stop learning you can
always pick up new skills you know
sentence them to working like next door
at a bicycle shop say Hey you have to
worked with this guy for six months
learn everything he can everything you
can so you could if he if he died
tomorrow you could take this place over
so I think there's a lot of room for
creativity in our criminal justice
system that we're not taking advantage
of whether it's because it's an ulterior
reasons of making money or keeping
people marginalized in society I don't
know I mean the truth is out there I
mean it's probably a little bit of both
as many layers and complexities to this
world but that's that's what I would
like to see going forward in
um in my line of work and I think we're
doing the same thing over and over again
and expecting different results which is
the definition of insanity so
people watching this if there's any
people of influence let's try something
else let's move forward past putting
somebody in a box which is very inhumane
uh very few people I think go into
prison and come out better I've seen a
few but I've seen way more that it makes
it worse and it's just obvious you just
take an animal and you keep them in a
crate you treat them like garbage you
beat them you give him horrible food
give him a horrible atmosphere he's not
going to come out and be a loving caring
pet same thing with a person we're just
animals like anything else we just have
the abilities to tell stories like this
what are your thoughts on
good guys and bad guys because you know
the cops are typically the good guys and
and you're chasing down the
bad guys but
we're all just humans when you boil it
all down and we're capable of good or
bad correct I'm sure there's guys in the
police department who are doing some bad
stuff and I'm sure there's guys that are
lifelong drug addicts or gang members or
whatever and and there's there's good in
them as well
100 there's um mentor of mine who's
actually an ex-con he was one of the
youngest ex-cons to enter San Quentin
prison people might know him he was a
very prolific author's name was uh
Edward bunker Eddie bunker and he uh
gave me a quote she wrote out on a piece
of paper is unbelievable he said if I
can get it right it says not all the
good guys are good and not all the bad
guys are bad but only the good ones can
tell the difference so
I know plenty of good people have done
horrible things and I've encountered
many bad people that have done good
things
probably somewhere you know the major
part of society was somewhere in the
middle and you have those extreme ends
of saints and then you have the rest
that are just the ultimate of evil and
but everyone else can be influenced in
between it's just with that product of
environment is or if they have had good
schooling a good parenting or a good
mentorship and it pushes them the other
way so that decision can be made every
day it's it's made by me I try to come
in here or just starting work I say okay
in my mind like what's my intention for
the day like what do I ever want to
accomplish
um uh yesterday I screwed up I you know
I treated uh so in bad or I was I was
short with people or just in a bad mood
today going forward I'm gonna as dry as
I'm driving here I want to let people
going forward me I don't want to speed I
want to be a caring driver I want to be
very cautious I want to you know give
people a thumb thumbs up or when you're
at a red light look over and smile those
little things have Ripple effects
through society and within you so in the
police departments like anything else
we're just people where your neighbor
where your husband where your cousin we
just happen to enter a profession and
there's some people out there in my
profession that have done horrible
things and
we do everything we can and to get them
out
fire them imprison them
and everyone else we try to build them
up and so every day I send my guys out
there we had that decision and it's it's
everything's by mood I mean you could be
a great person but something just
happens at home and rattles your cage or
someone someone on the street that you
encounter says the wrong thing to you
and boom you could snap and make the
wrong decision right then and there and
you could be the best of persons best of
best of have a great heart but take that
extra second and then boom someone get
thumb sewing or write him a ticket
erroneously or just being a prick and
really giving someone a bad day it's
like one of my mentors says instead of
have a nice day says give a great day so
I've seen some I've worked with some
unbelievable people that are almost
close I mean close to sainthood I would
say like go out there and really do
God's work and there was some people I
was like man this guy does not belong in
this profession he is horrible and
luckily from what I've seen the the
system has spit those people out some
stay of course and we see those
headlines every day we've seen the
videos but for the most part
um great people I've had the opportunity
of working with like I said through
three decades but yeah it's a job and
it's comprised of humans and humans are
messy and they're capable of some
animalistic horrible things yeah you
work in some some of the roughest
neighborhoods
in the country you know South Central
L.A and skid rower two of the worst yeah
Brooklyn Brooklyn North and Bushwick in
uh the 2000s and Times Square in the in
the 90s I've seen some really horrible
uh places where like this nation's truly
number one like how could how could we
how could this be a byproduct what do we
what are we doing wrong what are we
doing to fix that and here in particular
in skid row it's just a it's an
embarrassment as a U.S American it's
like wow these are problems we should we
could have solved ages ago it's like how
are we in 2022 still not rectifying that
um it's it's it pains me every day what
are your thoughts on what the solution
might be
well the the thing what I could firmly
grasp is going to be simple I know that
yes it's or or could be simple but it's
complex
simple not easy but
uh I almost look at it as like a one
through ten like the where the police
come in where maybe at like seven or
eight it's almost like a asking a heart
surgeon like how could what are you
doing how can you we have all this heart
disease what are you doing about curing
heart disease and he's like hey I'm I'm
at the I'm at number 10 I'm the one
that's going in surgery and fixing this
guy I didn't create this problem so
that's where I'm like I didn't create
this problem so we got to backtrack this
to the beginning so it all comes down to
literally the minute you come out and
you're or even probably before that
prenatal care or
um how are people being raised before
they're even born or do parents
especially in underprivileged
neighborhoods do they have access to
prenatal care and good environments or
the mental skills to learn how to Bear a
child
um and then when that child is born what
kind of food is it being given what kind
of guidance what kind of atmosphere
environmentally
um there's a lot of the lack of good
Role Models is what's like such a
glaring
[Music]
as Role Models when I was young
and then I go to like South Central or I
go to Skid Row and I see there's nothing
for these people there's nothing for
them to look up to and say oh I'd like
to be like that person one day yeah I
aspire to do this I just you know it's
aspire to do what they sell drugs
yeah yes you're born pretty much into
using baseball vernacular you you
stepping up the plate with strike two
yeah and a lot of people do get out of
it but a lot more than more than more
than too many of them don't and it's not
their fault and that's why there's these
programs that get people giving them
more an advantage of someone else that's
growing up in a in a permissive
environment and people have to
understand that you know we have to I
think a lot of like social programs get
a bad bad rap Christmas people abusing
them but there were people like I said
that walking up to the plate strike two
that need these services and we could we
could do a lot more for people just just
in the in the environments we're
creating for people living is is
horrendous air quality food quality just
resources to good Parks clean streets
that are free of debris sound and noise
there's so much that comes into play
where I live it completely changes my
mood when I'm that's kind of one of the
good things selfishly that I I like
liked working in Skid Row like the
minute I left that my police station and
I see they're all just this cacophony of
just human Madness and as I'm getting
closer to my neighborhood I just feel
that toxicity draining from my from my
body and so seeing a good environment uh
Beach and sunshine and paved roads and
happy people that immediately changes my
mood so the people that are living in
neighborhoods that have the opposite
they're in a constant fight of flight
feeling because everywhere they look is
a threat and then we just become a
product of our environments and we're
expecting people to do the opposite it's
like just when you're walking out the
door they already have a chip on the
shoulder and are on edge
and it's just and it's no fault of their
own no they see no opportunity
yeah like like in these neighborhoods
these people don't see any kind of
chance for Breaking Free breaking out of
this it's um it's pretty rare the the
one equalizer I think that's changed a
lot of Dynamics is the the internet you
know before growing up when I grew up
all I knew was my four square blocks a
couple of Knuckleheads that I lived in a
neighborhood in my family other than
that I didn't know about the rest of the
world I didn't know what Afghanistan was
or where it was and uh the other
opportunities that were out there
different skills but the internet any
kid you know has a phone or access to a
library or whatever can get on there and
see that this world outside of their
four square blocks that could be
surrounded with you know abusive parents
uh knucklehead neighbors
um you know abusive uh uncles and
whoever you know pimps in the street
prostitutes like hey this isn't this
this isn't the whole world like there's
something beyond that there is hope so
uh that Lifeline for me was books
fortunately or one of the lifelines I
was a voracious reader so I knew these
books were like a portal I mean that's
how I learned about it's a Los Angeles
police that's how I learned about the
West Coast culture seeing all this and
news outside of grimy New York City I
was like wow I I could live somewhere
else and experience all these different
things and um uh in a maritime rich like
environments and I was like incredibly
appealed to me so that that was my my
source of hope so how long have you been
in L.A
I came out here originally in 96 I've
moved back to New York City in 2000 and
came back out here in about 2004 so
played a little bit of hopscotch how do
they compare
oh it was night and day
uh one of the things I didn't understand
in La when I first came out to LA you
know of course it's sunshine and you
know all these beaches and just
beautiful people everywhere you know
where places I visited at the time I was
like why is everyone so angry
why is everyone on edge I was like if I
grew up here I'd be so happy and then
you know as you get older and you know
wiser you peel back the layers you find
out what makes people tick but if yeah
it was it was it was Paradise when I
finally came out here but I that's what
I was looking for but the rough
neighborhoods in New York are how do
they compare to the rough neighborhoods
in L.A
it's that's interesting it's a good
question the the main difference when
you're going through a rough
neighborhood and say like Chicago
Detroit uh Philadelphia New York City
like you just know immediately like wow
this does not look good it doesn't feel
good and then when you saw it seeing
people how they interact like this is a
I'm in a bad neighborhood like the the
ghettos in LA are very very deceiving
it's like these single family houses
Lawns even a projects uh once uh one
story two story projects so the projects
where I grew up and maybe just
monstrosities towers of just doom and so
aesthetically it looks good but then
when she like I said before you peel
back that layer you're like ah all right
this is a really tough neighborhood and
inhabited by some really really uh
impoverished people does your job get to
you emotionally
not anymore it did when I didn't have
the tools to really uh to recognize how
to mitigate mitigate those feelings of
uh of Despair and lack of Hope and the
stress has got to just build and build
and build it does it does it's it's
still there but now I just know how to
manage it you know to manage it through
many different ways and tools through
the years and that's one of my missions
now as a as a supervisor is to give my
guys those tools and let them not make
those mistakes that I did through you
know alcohol and sex and just
destructive living so
um yeah it was it was rough for a couple
years it got really dark and thankfully
I had tools available to me and uh good
people that got me through that and now
that I'm at that certain level I'm going
to push that back down and help others
again that life of service so whether
it's people on the street or within my
own organization everything's being
about of service how old are you now I
am 49 49. so you've you've seen and
learned a lot
living this life right I think the
hubris and me like oh yeah I've learned
a lot I've done a lot like no way I have
so much more to learn I have so much
more to go uh lifetime students I try to
be the teacher but I know I have a long
way to go and um every day I'm trying to
chip away that stone and get better and
be better you sound like you're
still happy with your decision to become
a
police officer oh absolutely I wouldn't
have traded it traded for the world it's
it's a it's a portal to lives that
you'll most people never get to touch
um similar to yours you're talking to
people from all along this all around
the Spectrum and policing offers you
that of talking from billionaires to
people that don't have a literally have
a nickel in their pocket and everyone
else in between and you're getting to
help people through all different stages
of their life and uh in the same time
hopefully helping yourself like with
those experiences enriching your life
enriching your spirit and it's been it's
been a great ride have there been any
opportunities in your life where you've
been able to help like an individual who
was obviously taking the wrong path and
steer him in a better Direction yeah
there's one that pops out
in my mind was I was thinking about it
before because there's a the bike shop
right over here there was an individual
it was actually a fellow New Yorker from
Brooklyn and I was uh working it under
kind of our capacity back in the early
2000s and
this individual from Brooklyn ended up
selling me narcotics and then when we
ended up apprehending him we had to
fight him uh
so he was we were good with it at the
end of it we didn't we didn't have to
hurt him you know we all just had a
couple of scrapes and bruises and all
that dusted him off said hey it's
nothing personal you know you can't uh
run and fight from us and he understood
that my guys understood that and long
story short he ended up going to prison
for you know maybe a year or two and
when I was hearing Skid Row I was just
getting uh getting done stopping someone
for whatever it was and I see this guy
on a bike racing towards me at full
speed so I just kind of stepped back and
this guy gets real gets off his bike and
he's got this huge smile I'm like what
the hell is this about and he comes
right up to me and he's like just
smiling looking at me I'm like okay uh
I'm like hey can I help you and he's
like yeah he's like you don't remember
me so I'm sitting there thinking I'm
like
um I mean I've talked to millions of
people I mean and stopped so many people
arrested so many people through the
years and it's clicking but not really
yet and then he's I'm like hey refresh
my memory he's like he's like I tried to
sell you drugs I'm like yes yes I
remember you so I asked him I was like
hey how are you doing and uh because he
looked completely different and he
emptied out his soul and told me he's
like man he's like that was the best
thing that ever happened to me I was
like tell me more and at the time I
remember speaking with him he said his
uh him and his uh old lady uh were going
at it they were fractured and he was
like an abusive type of guy and you're
just leaning a horrible lifestyle and he
said he got back with his got back with
his uh old lady he got off dope he
stopped selling drugs for that need and
he ended up getting a job working at a
bike shop repairing bikes and selling
bikes and you could see it in his eyes
he had Clarity facial struck she had
meat on him he just looked like a
healthy individual and uh so we hugged
and I was like hey you know keep in
touch is is my number here's my business
card and it's just rare to see that
because you know like I said we'd
working all over the city in the county
and to link up with people that you've
incarcerated through the years it's
happened once or twice a couple times
through my career and I mean that
just choosing that profession having
just that one ripple effect on that
person like that made everything else
worth it
um it's it was a beautiful thing they're
they're you know pressures that cops go
through
that I think a lot of people just don't
realize you know you guys go through
this stuff every day
like when you're approaching somebody
every any one of them can be a loose
cannon
yeah it's kind of like when I was
describing uh you know living in a
non-permissive neighborhood you're in a
constant state of fight or flight is
this uh is this person a friend is this
a foe so you're always in this um they
call it condition yellow there's like
three stages conditioned white I mean
just kind of walking through life
lackadaisical you're not thinking about
it like in your house there's no threats
condition yellow is when you're aware of
your surroundings and something could
possibly go wrong but you're not
paranoid you're not an edge you're just
very aware and then condition red when
you know violence is imminent and
something's about to go wrong or could
go wrong like when we're conducting a
raid doing a serving a search warrant or
on someone and you're ready you're keyed
up you're about to hit that door and
it's about to go down it's conditioned
red and then condition black is when
it's actually happening you're involved
in that kinetic activity of fighting for
your life or defending somebody and or
trying to commit a rescue or something
like that so the stress is always there
he's got to take a toll on it oh it does
I mean just just the simple fact of
entering a shift work occupation that
takes easily 10 to 15 years off your
life I think the national the World
Health Organization
um has acknowledged that that it opens
you up to cancer and shift work is
detrimental to your health so just
walking in the door and when you're a
rookie you're working nights and
weekends and no holidays for an extended
amount of time so that's stress on your
body and then you layered upon the
politics of policing the dangers out in
the street and then your own
self-inflicted wounds of medicating
those stresses and negative ways by you
know alcoholism bad food bad diet uh bad
environments a big thing that we don't
look at is our social diet everyone's
obsessed with what they're eating or
drinking but what you see what you put
out what you speak is just just as
important as what you what you take in
you know in a physical form into your
body and the police department could be
a real uh negativity is very contagious
there and it can be a constant people
bitching to moaning about you know I
can't wait to get home I'm done talking
to this guy I just want to I just want
to get the hell out of here I put in for
this holiday to get off and it got
denied to me so all these things that
just chip away at your soul that people
are a lot of people are unaware of so
when they encounter someone on the
street and so when a cop looks pissed or
treats them like crap not that it's
right it's that these are all the
underlying things that are in play
before before you even have that
encounter someone that's angry and
pissed already which is could be a
ticking time bomb out there so that's
why I try to do things like this and
really try to educate my occupation and
others out there of we have to take care
of ourselves before we could take care
of anyone else
are there any particularly interesting
stories of what you've been through on
the streets
yeah there's one that always pops out my
mind it's beautiful and ugly and tragic
at the same time
it's back when I was a b cop working in
Hollywood we were backing up another
unit who got a radio call that one call
and uh
these 911 calls in the beginning you
don't get much information what it is so
it was just like someone needed help and
that was it dropped on the phone line
dropped so we go to back them up
we all show up and we're at this house
really ritzy part of Hollywood I think
like Andrew Dice Clay lived across the
street there were some players very
manicured neighborhood so usually
nothing nothing too much would ever
happen in this particular neighborhood
so what kind of
lacks a lackadaisically walking up like
ah what is it what is it some kind of
false alarm dummy you know it's we
should never do that we should go into
every situation knowing could be a
problem and this time it was a problem
we pie off from the door and look
through the window and we see an
individual laid out in supine position
and I don't want to get too graphic but
he was completely nude he was his
genitalia was removed and it was laying
besides him and then upon closer
examination once we breached the door he
had I believe a watch covering his eyes
so we walk in and uh oh he had a
fireplace poker
that you stir fireplace with sticking
out of his chest
so this obviously isn't your thing that
we see every day so we walk in and
there's something like out of the movie
Seven like wow what the hell is this
what did we just walk into and it's uh
even us guys have seen a whole lot it
took us by surprise
so we immediately see that we start
clearing the rest of the residents
looking to see if anyone else is inside
the house any victims or any
perpetrators and we make entry into this
bedroom and all we see is a head and
nothing else
so
in the primary residence where we first
saw it was a complete body with the
genitalia next to it and then just his
head and then when we clear the rest of
the place we don't see the body
and we didn't really see a blood trail
or anything like this is random head
like wow we've
we've got something right here this is
uh this is one for the books and so we
start going through all the normal
homicide protocols we establish a
perimeter get a crime scene going and
the whole rigmarole that you see on TV
we start you know calling in detectives
and everything else so while we're going
through all the steps one of the steps
is uh canvassing the neighborhood for uh
possible Witnesses people that could add
you know to the scenario what did you
hear what did you see what have you and
in this particular part in Hollywood
out here in La people are from everyone
from all over the Spectrum a lot of
people don't know the neighbors uh
myself included I'm guilty as charge at
some of my neighbors I don't know and I
should do concerted effort to do that
note to self but I digress this this
um
block
um every almost every person I
interacted with uh knew this victim and
which was very rare because this person
was a these people
were very special in our in our world
and I'll add to that as it goes on so
they're telling us uh this person was a
doctor and uh with us utmost character
very loving very caring great neighbor
great person so we're just in taking all
this information we're like wow uh this
unbelievable person just got killed in a
horrific way
so we're canvassing enabled speaking all
these people we're hearing this guy's
bonafides just ridiculous and we get
another 9-1-1 call at a house uh across
the way from this person on another
block and like like what the hell now
and it ended up so we all rushed over
there and uh turns out to be another it
was a hum they said it was a homicide in
progress so we show up and there's this
little old lady sweetest old lady it
could be someone's you know reminding me
of uh my grandma is he sitting on a
stoop
and see he's just Crest Fallen like
you've taken everything from her life
just drained her of a soul so I get down
to her level like you know ma'am what's
wrong you call the police what happened
and she's like yes yes
um my boyfriend is inside and he's dead
so this 80 something year old lady I was
like boyfriend I'm like well that's kind
of strange and then I'm like he's dead
I'm like oh boy what the hell is this so
like okay ma'am sit here let's move you
to the side and let's get you some help
and now we have to enter this residence
and clear it find out what we have so we
end up opening breaching that residence
and
um
it was all steam it was like I don't
know if anyone's seen if you've seen a
movie insomnia with uh Al Pacino there's
this part in a movie where he's going
through Alaska and is all this fog and
he's searching for a perpetrator and the
fog is you know so thick they can't see
past his hand and that's what I related
to uh the heat was turned up to this
house to the maximum and all the water
in the house was turned up so it was
just all Steam and the steam they said I
couldn't see past my hand and now we're
looking for a homicide suspect and we
don't know what's going to pop out or
what we're going to see
so we ended up clearing the resonance
and we find we find the body where
obviously the head came from and the
other residents so as a body without a
head and it's completely filleted like a
like you like a canoe just someone
completely opened up looked like organs
were removed and just completely
obliterated it was something that you
kind of see at the coroner's office as a
homicide detective or investigator but
much more brutal and ritualistic it
seemed and
we go through the rest of the house and
then we come back out and speak to
um we speak to the elderly woman and
they were so sweet they were dating she
said and uh that was his boyfriend and
they knew each other I think maybe about
10 years or so and they would have lunch
every day today and she just happened to
find him in that state and I just
thought that was so horrendous to have
to see a loved one in that condition and
in that stage of their life but then
again it was so sweet that people in the
80s were still dating unbelievable that
warmed my soul and and tore it apart at
the same time so as the investigation
continued what we found out was there
was this very uh deranged individual
with a shattered backgrounds he was a
ex-marine and he was uh spun out on
methamphetamine and this is this is by
his uh by his words and he was going
through the neighborhood and just
knocking on doors and it's the morning
time you know people no one's opening up
doors uh but who you know all elderly
people that uh uh possibly lonely or
just living in that pre you know that
Camelot era of where you opened up doors
to strangers see what they need or what
have you and he opened up the door and
um the perpetrator punched him right in
the face
this 80 something year old man and when
you punch somebody in the face you know
particularly in the mouth it's uh it's
why we we teach open hand strikes so you
don't break your hand you punch them in
the in the mouth and his hand
immediately swolled and in his range the
war warped mine he got completely
enraged he thought it was because of the
elderly man's uh bad dental hygiene and
then completely took out the rage yet he
just broke his hands on his face and
thought it was the man's fault and just
completely you know committed the most
horrific acts that I've ever seen in my
career you know sexual acts ritualistic
acts like I said of removing his head
removing organs and just doing complete
depravity of that human beings shouldn't
be capable of and then once he removed
his head he took off his belt and
wrapped it around through his uh through
his throat and his mouth and put it over
his shoulder and like a gunny sack and
hopped the fence and to his neighbor and
into the doctor's house so he he's got
this head on through this belt and he
goes through
breaches hit the Doctor's house who just
happened to be on the line with uh with
an airline agency with his airline
agency I think it was in somewhere back
East maybe in Georgia or whatever so be
back before the internet where you could
book everything online you do the old
school way on the phone give you credit
card information and so he's on the
phone with booking his airline ticket
and he looks over and sees his madman
with a head and coming at him so he
drops the phone and the operator on the
line hears his brutality going on and
that's when they generated the 9-1-1
call to us and
he
did those acts that I described to the
doctor
ended up taking his keys to his car and
then ended up fleeing and then ended up
getting caught in a
he was in Hollywood and by that time his
picture got plastered all over the news
and a security guard from Paramount
Studios I believe
sees this guy scaling a wall at
Paramount Studios and says oh what the
hell is this some guy's scaling the wall
and then he's like wait a second that's
the guy that was just on the news I
think that the news feed was still on
there like the little command post and
they call 9-1-1 my guys get there and
capture him so
he goes to goes to prison what have you
but years down the road I'm
I'm at a doctor's office and I'm getting
uh getting my moles checked out which I
got to do again Irish skin is horrendous
and uh
so I'm talking to this doctors the first
time I'm seeing him so we're doing a you
know getting to know you game you know
oh what do you do for a living oh how
long have you been in a doctor all that
stuff and uh I asked him I was like hey
how did you get into this line of
business uh you know particularly you
know dealing with Dermatology and what
have you like oh yeah he's like um I was
I came from a real shattered home a
horrible lifestyle broken down family
and one of my friends just happened to
be his dad was a doctor I was like oh
really okay and he goes you know he
became a surrogate father for me and I
really loved him he loved me and he
mentored me and I wanted to follow in
his footsteps and live his life of
service so I ended up he ended up
putting me through medical school I was
like wow that's that's beautiful that's
that's something else and uh and then as
he's continuing the story he tells me
yeah unfortunately he got killed I was
like oh well it's like what happened and
then he starts relating the story
of what I just described to you he was
the doctor that everyone in the
neighborhood loved and he was the one
that put him through Medical School
became that surrogate Father Figure and
ended up getting killed which was I mean
it just shows that it's a cycle of life
of of uh of the darkness and the light
all in one and the other figure that got
ended up getting killed the elderly man
that was had the elderly girlfriend he
ended up being a screenwriter that did
all of all the old school like Abbott
and Costello meets the Frankenstein and
Three Stooges he was a real big
screenwriter and he became the victim to
McCarthyism he got erroneously singled
out for being a communist which is he
wasn't got blackballed and that was the
end of his career but that didn't that
didn't stymie his uh love uh as well as
being a good person of course he too
when we canvassed the neighborhood uh
talking to his neighbors and possible
Witnesses they said the same thing this
guy was Aces he was just an unbelievable
person and um everyone loved him so we
encountered these two Souls that were uh
were mentors and changed people's lives
that went through adversity and through
some of the toughest times in our
country and then got
brutalized and killed ended their
beautiful lives in such a tragic way and
it just really encapsulates of what I
seen in life of how we could destroy and
uplift people and it's just these people
all around us we just have to make those
choices of who we want to be and who we
want to follow
wow that's a great story terrible story
but interesting as can be
you've been doing this long enough to
answer this question I think
do you see us as a society getting
better or worse
more violent more I I struggle with that
thought I'm a I'm an optimist at heart
and we can get better and I think there
are aspects that are getting better but
then I see other aspects deteriorating
so it's like I think we you can we're
getting better and worse at the same
time if that makes sense it's changing
yeah it's just our environment has
changed I know there's a lot of angry
disenfranchised Souls out there in every
occupation every source of life and my
my job as providing being of services as
being a peacekeeper so trying to keep
peace Within Myself and to others and
I can't stress that enough of how
there's so much hate and
disenfranchisement out there in the
world and one little simple gesture
could change someone's trajectory and
stop them from causing violence uh
within the household road rage on the
street whatever it is
um like I said just came back from
driving so it's like when you let
someone in in front of you just a simple
gesture like oh wow okay oh thanks that
was really nice and the chances that I'm
doing that to someone in the immediate
future a lot higher and now you could
have just prevented a possible road rage
or a shooting or something crazy or that
guy coming home to his uh family after a
tough day at work and taking it out on
them so we our choices are so critical
every every little second counts and has
an effect on society as a whole so
is society getting better I know I'm
getting better so
I really try to be intentional with my
actions now as opposed to the past where
I then have those tools
that's great
Jim what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned
in your in your life
the most important lesson it's easy just
be kind
you know some of the most happiest
people I know that I've encountered
through life had zero on zero people
here in Skid Row or in Venice Beach
they didn't have a pot to piss in and
they were super happy laughing fun
gregarious people living life by their
own uh by their own means being an
outlaw uh whether good or bad and some
of the people that I know that are
millionaires are completely horrible so
just being kind to yourself that's being
so hard I have to remind myself if for
my failures and or if I didn't rise to
the level of my standard yesterday I'm
like I can't beat myself down
um or anyone around me I'm like I could
just be kind to myself and say let's
just do better so that doesn't cost any
money it doesn't really have you know it
doesn't take any schooling so that's
active kindness if you walk into the
world just trying to be kind to yourself
and others everything else will work
itself out for the most part
that's excellent Jim thank you so much
for coming in and talking with us and uh
wish you the best of luck out there I
absolutely I appreciate the opportunity
Mark keep on doing this great work thank
you very much